they're still distinct thank you for
your patience we're ready for the final
talk of the day which is by andreas
bless okay so I gave a title here that
lists a lot of topics I don't actually
promise to get to all the topics in half
an hour but we'll see how far I get
there's three pieces of mathematics in
one piece of physics here so even though
the physics is listed last I'm going to
talk about it first to get it out of the
way this is also the part that's most
relevant to computation Amiens so I need
to tell you what they are and why would
make care about them
and so I can't hear you it is not
possible for me to make it bigger and
maybe possible for experts to make it
bigger but no I don't think so because
it's already using the full screen here
it looks real big to me okay so a neons
are very small objects as you see any
ants it says here are particle like
excitations that can exist in
two-dimensional space I need to explain
a couple of things about that first of
all this is an aspect of quantum theory
quantum computing and so on and particle
like excitation is pretty much the same
as particle if you get right down to it
because even what you normally call
particles like electrons and photons and
stuff like that are in fact from the
point of view of quantum field theory
excitations of a certain field so
particle excitations literally would be
synonymous with particle but don't take
physics literally that's one of the
lessons I've learned the real meaning of
particle like excitation seems to be
that you treat them like particles until
that starts to look absurd and then you
say oh they're not really particles the
only particle like excitations and you
get to make exceptions to all the usual
rules I personally have not yet gotten
the hang of when you're allowed to make
exceptions I think it's just before you
arrive at a contradiction
by the way that that that idea this is
going to be the one piece of actual
logic in my talk that idea is a familiar
one actually from logic showing that the
derive ability conditions are needed for
the girdle incompleteness theorems I
think it was Ferriman who pointed out
that you can give a perfectly good
definition in arithmetic of what the
girdle numbers of the axioms of piano
arithmetic are such that the consistency
is provable on piano arithmetic you just
say an axiom is something which
satisfies the usual definition of axiom
and it and all the earlier axioms
together do not lead to a contradiction
of provably consistent so same idea here
just if you if you're about to get a
contradiction don't okay two dimensional
space this is another potential problem
because we seem to be in a three
dimensional space here how do things get
to beat excitations or particles or
whatever in a two dimensional space
there's something obvious in a non
obvious way the obvious way is that the
thing whatever it is should be confined
to a very thin layer of something or
other or perhaps to the boundary of some
solid object or something of that sort
there is however another way the things
can be de facto two-dimensional namely
by being infinite in the third dimension
if you have a a long solenoid with the
current going around like this producing
a magnetic field going through the
middle if that's long enough compared to
the horizontal dimensions then in effect
these things are acting like
two-dimensional objects these huge
cylinders move around and our dispell
position is described like two
parameters so it's entirely possible to
have mathematically two-dimensional
things happening in a three dimensional
actual space so that part is not quite
as fishy as the particle-like excitation
okay what can we do with these anions
the important property of aliens for our
purposes is that if you move any ants
around each other the state can change
I'm going to pretend that this
whiteboard is the 2-dimensional world in
which these antion's live and if you
have several of them sitting here and
you for instance interchange the
position of two of them move this one to
here and move that one to there
if this were any ants of the same sort
the final state works just like the
initial state quantum mechanics says
state is determined by a Hilbert space
vector up to a phase factor this can
produce a different phase factor it can
in fact because these are Amiens and in
a two dimensional space could use more
complicated effects than phase factors
and that's going to be much of the
importance of antion's
for quantum computing it's also going to
be much of what I need to talk about in
this talk when I get to the other three
topics in my title so it says on the
slide even if every ant ion returns to
its initial position so that means if
you do this interchange twice it may
still be the result may still be
something different from what you had in
Detroit the reason anybody in
computation is interested in these
things is twofold first of all these
operations of moving these things around
for use in the end unitary operations on
the states of the system and those
unitary operations can be used as
ingredients of quantum computation
algorithms so one idea here is to be
able to do quantum computation simply by
providing a supply
Amiens and then moving them around
according to some while some quantum
program the second important ingredient
is that the unitary transformation that
you get by moving the anions in a
certain way doesn't depend on the detail
so if I go up here with a shaky hand and
move them around like that it will still
produce the same result as if I moved it
nice and smooth like the effect on the
system what happens in the computation
depends only on the topological
properties of which Amiens that you move
around which other ones and so on not on
the details of how you move them that
means that small errors like a shaky
hand or shaky instrumentation or general
problem environmental interference in
your computation is less likely to cause
errors in the quantum computation when
it's based on topological phenomena of
this sort so the hope is that there will
be fewer errors less need for error
correction
maybe I should repeat something which I
okay the following is not something I
know I'm just repeating what I was told
that in most situations that people have
designed for trying to do quantum
computation by far the largest part of
what needs to be done during the
computation is error correction in
contrast to classical computation my
understanding is that machines like this
essentially don't bother with error
correction because errors are so rare
and anyway it doesn't make any
difference that's probable of those may
be an overstatement but something along
those lines is true so this is why
anions are a potential use for
computation and why people like you and
i i should it was written on the title
slide but i didn't actually say that you
is is my co-author on all of this
material
on the other hand I don't think I've
actually shown him any of these slides
so he's not responsible for whatever
mistakes I make okay so that's why
Microsoft and others I think I BM also
are interested in things of this sort oh
good and young models this is much
better than any any answer in physics
any on models of in mathematics so we're
making progress here on the other hand
any on the standard any on model is
modular tensor categories which have a I
think it's a a truly marvelous
definition that will not fit into this
talk so I'm going to tell you a little
bit about what goes into an aunty on
model nowhere near the complete story
and in fact I'm going to specialize to a
particular model very soon but the
general one general aspect in ante on
models is they tell you what happens if
you bring two anions together and what
them interact and the general situation
is that there are various possibilities
that could come out they may annihilate
they may produce another ante on of a
different sort they may use a different
end of the same sort all kinds of things
can happen different models have
different specifications for that I'm
going to be talking mainly about one
particular model named after somebody
who was long before any quantum
computations or any ons or anything of
that sort so this is sort of the ideal
thing for a mathematician to get your
name so thoroughly embedded in the
language that it shows up are things
that you've never dreamed of so what if
it Bonacci aeneas we haven't actually
any ins tau is a simple Fibonacci anyon
at least it is in this talk it is in
some other places to the fusion rule
this is to be read as if you take a
Fibonacci n young and another Fibonacci
n young and fuse them together the
result will be a Fibonacci a neon or
vacuum one is the vacuum
the identity for multiplication so the
multiplication operation here is bring
them together the plus is alternative
options of what can happen so vacuum is
called one because if you bring a vacuum
together with anything you've got the
anything that acts like a unit for the
multiplication this equation if you read
it in terms of numbers if you pretend
the Tau is a number and times of plus or
ordinary arithmetic operations that
quadratic equation has two solutions the
positive one of which is the golden
ratio and that gets you pretty close to
Fibonacci already so that's Fibonacci
fusion rule so Fibonacci onions are
simply by definition any ants that obey
that fusion rule and there's a picture
that any unfused download in my pictures
so 2n 2 to Fibonacci any ants fusing to
one or annihilating each other fusing
two vacuum yeah unfortunately this is
getting dangerously close to physics
again so in the usual model this is
indeed non-deterministic and in fact
these things live inside these
possibilities fusion possibilities are
represented by vectors in different
Hilbert spaces on the other hand I can
given enough time point you to a place
in the literature where it says that
these two are alternatives to each other
and tells you what the probability of
each is it does not tell you under what
circumstances those probabilities are
valid some restriction on the
circumstances is certainly needed and we
have asked and I don't think we ever got
an answer about when are those alleged
probabilities
actually correct that's why one thing of
the physics out of the way
as early as possible to get it far away
from the question period at the end of
it let's see if three Fibonacci onions
here are the two here are two ways to
fuse them to one Fibonacci n young in
these pictures are fusing the left pair
first it can produce either another
Fibonacci onion or vacuum and whichever
produces can then fuse with the one on
the right
to produce another Fibonacci Aniyah
there's a third process which is not
shown here because it doesn't fit the
title three Fibonacci onions confuse to
vacuum by first fusing two one ami on
here and then that one and this one
confused to vacuum so there are actually
three options by the way one option for
fusing two vacuum two options for fusing
to a single ami on three altogether this
is the beginning of the Fibonacci
sequence
if and everything is justified here
these two fusion processes as I
mentioned an answer to four counts
question the fusion processes are for
some reason actually considered to be
the vectors in the hilbert space and
these two fusion processes span well
since the two of them expand a two
dimensional hilbert space and this is a
qubit the quantum analog of a bit so a
bit is one of two elements of a two
element set a qubit is a state in a
two-dimensional Hilbert space and they
are analogous from classical to quantum
computation now I adapt at a fairly
arbitrary convention he refusing the
left pair first you confuse the right
pair first
and I was too lazy to draw another
picture but you can imagine it or you
can get behind the blackboard and look
from the other side and if these things
are really too small you may see just as
much you get another basis for the same
Hilbert space they are not the same
basis theirs they're both orthonormal
bases but they're related by some
non-trivial transformation the unitary
transformation which it says here it is
completely determined up to
normalizations this is not always the
case more complicated fusion rules may
leave you several choices for how these
things match up but in the case of
fibonacci things are simple there's only
one option up to normalizations means
changing one of the basis vectors by a
phase factor or something like that and
in fact here is the transformation you
may notice that Q is very close to the
golden ratio it's got a minus where the
golden ratio never put this is actually
the reciprocal of the golden ratio aq
and it's square root show up in here and
this was one of the few places where I
can be sloppy and actually get away with
it the unitary transformation
transforming one basis to the other I
decide which way which one gets
transformed to which one fortunately
that matrix is its own inverse so it
will actually worked both ways one piece
of good luck here you see once you start
doing mathematics instead of physics
things are much nicer braiding braiding
is this sort of thing moving in eons
past that you start with a bunch of
anions conventionally wind up nicely and
numbered one two three four five six and
you move them around each other
ultimately returning to their original
positions
but perhaps doing far more complicated
things than this like leave most of them
alone and move this
around through here back okay like that
stuff like that okay so think of
braiding as moving a finite collection
of points in the plane through some
paths ultimately coming back either to
their original positions or perhaps
switching positions permuting where they
were but coming back ultimately to the
same set of six points if you want to
really do mathematics then you say what
you're looking at is the set of six
element subsets of the plane and you're
looking at the fundamental group of the
space of such six element subsets
all the ways that can be moved around to
return to the same set okay so let's see
I was the slides of braiding to a neon
so forget the rest of the six and think
of these two passing one in front of the
other when I think you're in front think
of viewing the picture from below so
this one is passing in front of that one
when you interchange them this one
behind would be the arrows in the
opposite direction okay um I need to
draw some pictures ultimately in fact
before I do that I'll draw a picture of
this the problem with this picture is
that we're looking at the whole plane
and the temporal aspect is just me
waving my hand it's better if you draw
the temporal aspect so you get something
like this you have you have points here
at one time you have the points here at
a later time and they move from the
earlier to the way so you're drawing
like the world lines of the sense of
relativity theory like that and I mark
the cross with a little break to
indicate that this guy passed in front
of that guy while the others I guess
just sat there
and did nothing about right that's done
in some sense afterward it's the fusion
rule determines what's going to happen
in the braiding but you're not actually
fusing anything here you're moving them
around and that ultimately the fusion
might be considered notice the vagueness
in the physics here might be considered
as a way of measuring the final state of
the system fuels everything and see what
see what you end up with okay so if you
if you braid just two anions the fusion
process so here are the two fusion
processes the trees that you see there
are the ones that we saw a couple slides
ago the two ways to fuse two anions to
one what I've added here is if you were
to braid this one in front of that one
or in this configuration braid this one
in front of that one then the quantum
state involved would acquire a phase
factor rather strange phase factors
there's this Zeta in here which you can
infer from the equation but I can also
tell you Zita is a primitive fifth root
of unity it plus it's reciprocal gives
you the event queue the reciprocal
golden ratio from before and these
phases rather remarkably are again
forced you this is not something
somebody made up well there's something
Fibonacci made up it comes from the
fusion rules you can actually deduce
these things from the fusion rules okay
if you gotta break three or more
Fibonacci antion's
then you get more complicated fusion
rules okay I need to talk a lot faster
but I need to also draw this picture for
you if you were to braid these two
then depending on whether they were in
this picture where they used to tower
this picture where you fuse the one
you're going to end up with phase
factors like what we had on the other
slide if you're going to bring these two
you're in a different situation because
these are not fusing to Tao or the one
these are doing some other stuff first
and then fusing what you have to do is
go to this other basis where these two
are considered as fusing immediately
which means you're going to get the
stuff on the other slide those phase
factors conjugated by the unitary matrix
that we had here which means you're
going to get some non-trivial
stuff which I believe I did not write
down here just as well for three anions
fusing two fusing to one so this is the
cubic that we were talking about before
the two braids operations when we raid
the first two or braid blast to generate
a dense subgroup of the unitary group so
you get a good approximation any unitary
matrix you want given that we can
calculate that we can use three
Fibonacci anions fusing two one to
produce to serve as a qubit the producer
faces for two dimensional space door
twice take six Fibonacci antion's fuse
them to one fuse these two one just to
finish the job fuse those two to vacuum
why not they could fuse to one but I
want vacuum I'll tell you why in a
moment those six anions fusing to vacuum
can give you two qubits I again got
tired of drawing pictures so the four
good options are you could have either a
towel or vacuum here and still end up
with a towel that's your first qubit
same for your second qubit this one's
drawn backwards fusing in the right half
instead of the left half that's because
this is a contra
symmetry and I want the picture to be
symmetric you could do it the other way
but I like to do it this way and then
these two fuse to vacuum at the end it
says here four of the five options
correspond to the qubits that you want
the fifth option is where each side
individually fuses to vacuum and then I
guess to vacuums fuse to one vacuum
which is not much going on that's junk
that's not part of the two cubed space
that you want and one of the reasons
that you and I are worrying about these
things is the one wants to know how much
computation can you do how much braiding
can preserve the good space the four
cubed space rather than producing
results that have components in the
direction of the fifth the basis vector
at this point huh know exactly when I
started but I'm sure I don't have much
time we need to analyze the great group
which is the group of all thick braids
like this and compose them by just
setting one after the other pile them up
six strands because I'm talking about
six antion's there what I say about six
generalizes to end but I don't want to
draw in it's generated by whoops they're
too much here five so called Archon
generators because I can was the first
to study the break group this is art and
generator number three because it uses
great number three in front of number
four so generator number K puts braids K
in front of braids k plus one and it's
not too difficult to see that by
composing those you could get any
complicated configuration of braids the
braid generators satisfy two sets of
relations obvious ones if you're doing
two interchanges that are far apart from
each other
it doesn't matter in what order you do
them
there's an interesting one where the
adjacent ones commute and I was gonna
draw a picture of that but I think in
the interest of time I will say pictures
for later so you have a theorem of out
in the not very not so trivial theorem
of heightened is that those generators
and those relations suffice to
completely determine the very group that
is a presentation of the braids group
yeah high of a groups work just as well
the eight groups have some silly one
dimensional representations one
dimensional means instead of using a
matrix representation Allah matrix is
like a number so you're representing
each generated by a number and when you
do that this relation forces you to
represent all generators by the same
number so you're just doing some scalar
factor on the interesting there's also
interesting representations one that got
studied I think way back in the 1930s
called the Bohr our representation and
being that old it is indeed a well
studied representation fortunately I
don't have time to tell you any more
than what I actually know about it which
is very little there's a theorem a for
my neck from I think the nineteen
eighties that says that if you have an
irreducible representation of the
industry and braids group think six
strands for my example in a space of
dimension less than six like the five
from the five trees from the previous
slide then it's obtainable by taking a
product of one of those trivial one
dimensional scalar things and a
composition factor of a blow out
representation well except when n is
four five or six and six is the case
that I'm interested in and six is in
fact one of the representation that we
get from Fibonacci braiding is one of
the exceptional wonders
fortunately for manic also wrote down
the exceptional one and here it is now
yeah if this talk were infinitely long I
would give you a nice discussion if
these matrices are actually quite nice
but I will only point out that each of
them has on the diagonal two occurrences
of minus theta to the fourth one
occurrences in the first two one
occurrences in the last three columns
and once you know where those two
occurrences are the rest of the matrix
is completely determined ones on the
rest of the diagonal zeros above and
below the ones and then some non trivial
stuff above and below the diagonal Zeta
to the fourth if you really want to know
you should read the next slide much
faster than I can do it allowed the
matrices let me begin at the beginning
here these matrices that we got the four
Monica are not unitary so they represent
the Fibonacci situation which was the
unitary matrices but in a non
orthonormal basis they go to a weird
basis okay but they're nicer they don't
for instance involve that square root of
Q the entries of the Fibonacci of the
for my neck matrices are entirely
cyclotomic integers so things are nicer
in that respect the last paragraph that
wall of text up there that begins with
each of these can be completely
described that's saying how to read off
the whole matrix once you know whether -
ADA to the fourth side if you go if you
look at where those - theta to the
fourth Tsar I made a convenient list
here and you see as you go through the
width of our two generators one two
three four five you get to one two one
two looks nice and so mentally 5 3 4 5 3
gee there ought to be a 4 down there and
there won't be a 1 in the other column
there ought to be a 6 lighten generator
like that there it is why is it
this does deserve a picture instead of
starting with these six guys they're
around in a circle so here Arden here
are strands one two three four five six
just as each one can pass in front of
the next one and producer Nitin
generator you can do the same thing
we're passing in front now becomes
pressing outside the circle the
analogous thing up here gives you a
sixth group element analogous to the
item generators and when you workout
we're representing matrix is it's
exactly the thing you would want with
the zeta fourth in positions one and
four so that's nice and what I've
written here is just the description of
the red stuff but instead of lining them
up wrap them around in a circle that's
not a full description though I could
have wrapped them around in a circle
this way does it matter
it matters to the brave group those are
different
big boob elements that you get as the
sixth analog of Sigma one through five
but fortunately they both represent the
same thing in the Fibonacci
representation now if I'm right my next
slide is going to say hecka algebra and
I think rather than talking excessively
long about Hecky algebra so I will just
say there's a bunch of stuff on slides
about hecka algebras here actually I
think it's only two slides one two
that's it okay and it ends with needing
a 695 dimensional cone or something or
other that remains mysterious in fact
all 695 dimensional things that we see
please and I think that's how I'll be as
good a place to stop since I'm already
slightly over time thank you
any questions can you address okay the
the basic question that I would love to
know the answer to is this look at that
five dimensional representation of the
braids group in terms of the five
generate five basis vectors
corresponding to what I called the four
desirable matrices and the fifth one so
I have five dimensional standard
orthonormal basis a four dimensional
subspace is where the qubits that I'm
interested in live a five dimensional
subspace of the fifth dimension is there
because none that has to be there I am
no choice about it what I would like is
to be able to do braids goop operations
some complicated braiding steps that
will map this subspace into itself so
that I'm actually able to do
computations with those two qubits
without worrying about those now there
are great operations that will do this
for one thing if I do any braiding I
want on just these three or on just
these three or if I just pick up these
three and move them all past that but
none of those get me really anything
that combines the two qubits so one
question called the leakage problem is
you don't want to leak into this
subspace is are there elements of the
braid group which map this four
dimensional subspace into itself and are
not trivial in the sense that I just
described and this has apparently been
an open problem for quite a while and
yeah I guess the main result of our work
is
that it motivates lots of interesting
stuff but we still we're beginning to
see why it's been an open problem for a
while these topological qubits were
invented with the idea that one would
rely that is a good reason for wanting
to solve the leakage problem and do this
do the computations without leakage but
yes there's going to be there certainly
is going to be a problem as long as you
have leakage I mean you can make the
leakage small that that can be done you
can make it extremely small but some of
these quantum circuits require very long
iteration you do this gate and that gate
necking then and if each one has small
leakage and it starts to accumulate you
can get very serious problems so it it
does seem to be really worthwhile to
avoid the leakage in order to be able to
do genuinely quantum genuinely
topological quantum computing on that
space without having this one get in the
way the only thing you draw was what
braids you're using how are you moving
the anions around each other so you need
you need to look for fancy elements of
the braid group that preserve a four
dimensional subspace but don't do it for
trivial reasons
you could you could yeah yeah you can
control you can measure stuff in the
five dimensional space still preserving
something but it well the exact answer
to what have you computed yes but the
exact answer to what were you trying to
compute in this four dimensional space
that's more questionable and it gives
them nice interpretations of Scylla it's
a basic quantum gates that one uses in
also nice pictures or the basic quantum
gates that one uses to UM we can see
pictures nice pictures I haven't seen it
so for example there's a paper of a
cache that contains what the end if I
remember correctly a picture of a braid
that gives a very good approximation to
a see not gate which is one of the basic
ones that you always use you say well
you have to remember that in the quantum
circuits that people actually want to
work with extremely long so if you have
something like this that was I don't
know or there may be fifty enjoyed
twenty-eight generator as long that's
that's not that bad a factor of 28 in
the length of your overall quantum
circuit is well you know you'd rather
have a factor of two
about 2018 is I think quite tolerable
and I'm not sure that this 28 is up I
mean it was just that here is a way to
get a good approximation so always no
one attempted to optimize that so it may
be that one can do better and that's you
know one of the things that you and I've
been trying to do is compute a lot of
stuff and see see what you can achieve
yeah I can say to agonize maybe I should
say more than two words
Hecate algebra is what you get if you
take the group aldra so first of all
thank you for the group embedded as a
basis of an algebra using the group
operation on the basis vectors and
extend linearly so you're looking at a
group algebra representation of the
group like the things we've been talking
about is also a representation of that
algebra but these representations are
exceptionally good because the the group
sorry the matrices that represent these
basic braids that just switch to even
though they're 5x5 matrices they're very
nice in that they have only two distinct
eigenvalues one with multiplicity two
and one with multiplicity 3 a heck of a
Luba it's what you get if you determine
what those two eigenvalues are and
impose on the algebra additional
relations saying that each of these
generators shall have only those eigen
value so if the eigenvalues are a and B
you say for each generator say Sigma
Sigma minus a times Sigma minus B equals
0 the quotient of the group algebra by
all of that but all of those for all the
generators is what's called the heck
algebra sometimes the Illawarra hecka
algebra and the representations that
we're getting are representations of
that algebra and the big advantage is
that the group algebra is this big
infinite dimensional thing the hecka
algebra for n strands is while
good news is finite-dimensional the bad
news is n factorial dimensional so when
you're doing three strands life is nice
you have six dimensional Hecate algebra
your four dimensional representation
because it's re four dimensional space
of matrices it's two by two matrices and
so there's a two dimensional kernel for
that and we know exactly what the kernel
is and everything is nice with six
strands you have 720 dimensional hecka
algebra projecting to five by five
matrices which is twenty five dimensions
and that's why I said at the end of all
of this that we end up with a six
hundred ninety five dimensional kernel
there and yes it remains mysterious I
think we should close off the questions